hi i'm mark and i'm the ceo and founder
of tungle we're really excited about
everything we've offered so far and
wanted to share that with you so we've
put a little contest that's going to go
until the end of october how does it
work well each time you
book a meeting on tuggle you get one
entry in our daily draw each time you
tweet about a meeting that you've booked
you get an entry as well in our daily
draw and then finally each time you put
a comment on our tungle fan page on
facebook you also have an entry on our
daily drop now what are we going to be
able to win in our daily draw pretty
straight forward first we want you to
come and have coffee with us so we've
included a tunnel coffee mug
second we want to have coffee in the
coffee mug so we're going to give you a
10 gift certificate either at starbucks
or at tim hortons
finally the other thing that we've done
is we've also going to include the
tungle grocery bag so that you can be
environmental friendly now being part of
that daily draw is not the only way you
can get the prizes each time you write a
blog post about us
you will also automatically get a prize
finally at the end of the contest we're
gonna have a top five tunnelers so the
people that booked the most meeting
until the end of october are
automatically gonna get the prizes there
are a lot more detail if you go to our
tunngle blog about our contest but at
the end of the day we just want to save
you time so just start tonguing
have a good day